non pour parler avec monsieur le premier
ministre se sont déroulés
dans une ambiance ambiance constructive
et d'affaires traditionnels pour la
russie et à l'encré nous avons réussi à
couvrir pratiquement tout est question
parce que l'entretien dure est
pratiquement cinq heures nous avons une
société de l'ensemble toutes les
questions et en plus la mise en oeuvre
et la finalisation des accords que nous
avons eues à budapest en 2019
nous avons marqué de nouveaux plans
d'ensemble est d'envergure pour le futur
et nous avons révisé en commun des
problèmes régionaux et globaux je tiens
à souligner que la hongrie c'est un
partenaire important pour la russie en
europe et malgré les situations il n'y a
aucun virus et la pandémie les chiffres
pour les onze mois précédents ont
augmenté de 30% jusqu'à 5 5 milliards de
dollars et les investissements de
l'autre côté font environ un milliard de
dollars
et
la commission commentant des russes
hongroise
démontre son efficacité en novembre
dernier par lors de sa séance a obligé
ce que nous avons discuté des projets
mutuellement avantageux dans des
industries différentes en plus l'énergie
c'était vraiment insurgés traditionnelle
dans nos relations la russie pendant des
années alimente la grille en combustible
de façon ininterrompue en couvrant
jusqu'à 55 % des besoins et environ 80%
de baseball en droit pour le gaz et
surtout c'est grâce aux contrats à long
terme qui ont été prolongées l'année
dernière qui vise à assurer la livraison
de gaz jusqu'à 2036 de cette façon les
consommateurs angoua ont des
possibilités d'acheter le gaz grâce aux
prix beaucoup plus bas par rapport ce
qui est proposé par le marché en plus le
territoire hongrois haye sur les le
transiter vers les conduites qui ramène
le gaz dans l'europe occidentale et la
hongrie confirmant son statut du
partenaire fiable et sûre du combustible
russe et nous sommes sûrs intensifier le
partenariat mutuellement avantageux dans
ce domaine compte tenu du rôle du gaz en
tant que combustible le plus naturel et
vert lors de la transition vers
l'écologie verte j'aimerais souligner
que le groupe hongrois moon un
participent à l'exploration des
gisements dans la région de hambourg au
ne sont en train
de produire environ 500 mille tonnes de
combustible en plus à nice n'est qu'en
ce que nous avons mis en place un usine
et qui va produire du bitume en plus la
russie l'amour y conduit est continue à
réaliser le projet d'une construction
d'une centrale nucléaire backs avec la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs qui
est vont permettre de doubler les
capacités de production jusqu'à
480 800 mégawatts en plus nous en
discuter des questions dans le domaine
de la coopération industrielle a en
particulier le projet qui prévoit la
livraison du bagout pour le chemin de
fer pour les états tiers au début de
l'année en cours les chemins de fer dans
les gîtes ont reçu environ 600 wagons
les plus modernes et confortables en
plus il ya encore les autres 700 wagons
qui vont arriver chez eux ce qu'ils vont
alimenter et assurer les bons salaires à
nos entreprises pour les deux parties
avec à mon collègue
monsieur orban nous avons aussi discuté
de la question du transit des
marchandises vers l'europe et les pays
des balkans et nous pensons il nous
considérons que dans ce domaine
pendant le premier semestre de l'année
en cours ce projet va s'intensifier en
plus nos coopérants dans le domaine de
la production des médicaments de la
médecine dans la lutte contre
l'infection encore navires us est et
comment il est connu la hongrie et la
pologne pays en europe qui a validé est
le premier pays à utiliser le vaccin rue
spoutnik vo ici a homologué le vaccin
russe en europe à nous avons livré
environ deux millions de doses de ce
vaccin il est déjà prévu de localiser la
production de ce vaccin en hongrie en
plus nous sommes en train d'étudier la
question qui prévoit la livraison du
vaccin ce pique nique light qui peut
être utilisé en tant que dose de rappel
parra pauvres et en comparaison avec
d'autres fabricants étrangers en plus il
y en encore un autre exemple de la
coopération dans le domaine de la
médecine je me tiens à souligner la
participation de guider au recteur dans
la mise à jour de notre usine à 9 rigaud
risqué en plus à obtenir car avec nos
partenaires en quoi nous avons construit
une usine qui produit des endoprothèses
et des implants évidemment nous avons
aussi discuté de la coopération
humanitaire des deux côtés parce que
nous avons un programme de la
coopération culturelle est jusqu'à
l'horizon 2034 l'année dernière avec
succès nous avons réalisé les jours de
la culture russe en ouvriers les deux
pays échangent de façon intense dans le
cadre de la coopération académique et
écoles supérieures nous sommes en train
d'organiser des expositions et des
événements futurs et en plus des
étudiants hongrois au bénéficie des
avantages
fournis par l'état russe et j'aimerais
remercier la grille pour l'approbation
de la demande russe pour
la mise en oeuvre de l'exposition
universelle expo 2030 comme elle est
connue pendant les cent soixante dix ans
un précédent notre pays participation
internationale et pendant le premier
expo qui s'est tenu à 1854 a déjà
représenté ses acquis et jusqu'à présent
nous avons jamais organisé chinois et
nous comptons sur le fait que moscou
entend que mega paula en développement
et en pleine croissance bénéficiera de
ce statut pour héberger l'expo
universelle de mai 30 pour présenter les
produits innovatrice dans différents
domaines en ce qui concerne les
différents problèmes internationaux nous
avons discuté des questions dans les
relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne
naturellement nous avons discuté des
questions lee à la résolution de la
situation en ukraine et la situation en
ukraine dans l'ensemble surtout dans le
domaine des droits de l'homme et surtout
les violations qui sont devenue
systémique et les partenaires hongrois
comme nous le connaissons entreprennent
des vraiment tentative très énergique
est pour que ce problème soit résolu et
nous avons échangé des opinions
concernant les propositions russes à
l'égard des états unis et de l'otan qui
prévoirait la livraison et la
présentation des garanties dans le
domaine de la sécurité
et un os qu'on nous sommes en train
d'analyser la réponse reçue de la part
de l'auteur etats-unis le 26 janvier
dernier et j'ai déjà informé à monsieur
le premier ministre hongrois que les
préoccupations russes ont été ignorés
nous n'avons pas pu
voir la mise en considération des
préoccupations russes surtout le refus
de placer les systèmes d'attaqué de
frappe à côté des frontières russes
surtout des bases
de l'alliance
surtout dans les frontières qui était
prévu dans l'acte fondateur entre la
russie le tombes datant de
1997 surtout chaque fois on nous dit que
les pays ont la possibilité de choisir
les moyens les procédés pour garantir
leur sécurité mais chaque fois ils le
font juste non seulement
dans le but pour donner à quelqu'un la
possibilté les procès des deux d'assurer
sa propre sécurité aussi c'est juste une
face et dieu formule de l'indivisibilité
de la sécurité mais l'autre partie de
cette formule dit qu'il n'est pas
possible de permettre le renforcement la
six cordes et de quelques uns au
détriment d'autrui un conclusion
j'aimerais remercier monsieur sorbonne
pour le travail fructueux et riche et je
suis sur le bilan de nom pourparlers
vont favoriser allahou renforcement de
la coopération dans tous les domaines
merci beaucoup de votre attention
je vous remercie monsieur le président
je voudrais remercier monsieur poutine
d'avoir cette opportunité de mener des
négociations avec vous aujourd'hui à
cause du virus decaux vide nous nous
sommes rencontrés dans un format un peu
extraordinaire
je n'ai jamais été à une table aussi
longue que celle que nous avons eue par
contre
malgré la distance qui était entre nous
je suis très content de pouvoir discuter
avec des temps de détailler d'une
manière aussi longue notre coopération
entre autres personnes dure depuis 13
ans déjà c'est la douzième fois qu'on se
rencontre
suit la situation géopolitique dans le
monde
je n'exagère est pas en disant que la
réunion d'aujourd'hui est la plus
importante
ma visite c'est une visite
de dumontier en de la paix
j'ai pu dire que l'union européenne
c'est
quelque chose d'unique il y a aucun
dirigeant dans l'union européenne qui
voudrait provoquer en conflit avec la
fédération de russie
c'est surtout important pour nous notre
partie centrale de l'europe j'ai pu dire
comment nous faisons l'interprétation de
l'histoire quand entre l'occident et
l'est
il y avait un conflit nous avons
toujours perdu la guerre froide de
longues années ont apporté à la hongrie
des souffrances voilà pourquoi nous les
hongrois et autres peuples de l'europe
centrale nous avons intérêt à ce que les
tensions entre l'occident et l'est soit
réduite nous avons intérêt à faire tout
notre possible pour que
la guerre froide soit prévenue et pour
réduire les tensions et les pressions
dans cette situation actuelle pour ne
pas laisser se produire ces choses là il
nous faut de négociations il nous faut
un dialogue je salue en dialogue entre
la fédération de russie et nos alliés
occidentaux
comme j'ai déjà dit quand je le dis
toujours à nos alliés il est extrêmement
important de poursuivre ses négociations
ce dialogue il est extrêmement important
d'appliquer tous les instruments
diplomatiques pour résoudre le conflit
qui réduire les tensions qu'est ce que
nous pouvons offrir nous pouvons offrir
le modèle hongrois
dans la politique il y à ce modèle en
croit nos 100 membres de l'otan et de
l'union européenne
pourtant nous pouvons tout de même on
var deux d'excellentes relations avec la
russie c'est possible qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour le faire en respect mutuel
la hongrie a toujours reçu du président
poutine poutine le respect elle nous
faisons preuve de respect envers la
fédération de russie monsieur poutine
également même si l'année dernière a été
difficile à cause de la pandémie cette
année a été la plus réussie dans les
relations bilatérales des deux pays
grâce à notre coopération nous avons pu
résoudre
d'importants problèmes à surmonter des
difficultés nous avons eu besoin de
vaccin pour lutter contre la pandémie
grâce à votre
décision neuf cent mille personnes en
hongrie on peut se faire vacciner par
votre vaccin russe deuxième question
l'énergie grâce à vous nous avons pu
prolonger notre contrat à long terme sur
les livraisons du gaz depuis la russie
il s'est avéré en effet que les les
contrats à long terme
relève d'une grande importance
nous avons l'intention
d'augmenter les transmet livraison
annuelle jusqu'en milliards mètres cubes
nous allons continuer à négocier ce
sujet dans l'avenir
la hongrie
va bientôt console usine qui produira
différentes max 1
par exemple on va également produire à
ce pique-niqué et j'espère qu'on pourra
convenir à ce sujet bientôt et commencer
la production
concernant la construction de la
centrale
atomique
nous attendons la dernière licence ce
qui veut dire que les processus
automatique passeront la deuxième étape
ce sera l'étape de la construction
ce sera une grande réussite pour notre
pays parce que
nous avons l'intention de parvenir à une
indépendance énergique du pays d'une
manière à nice neutre envers le climat
dans le cadre de notre coopération entre
la russie et la hongrie nous avons pu
créer une une suscité ferroviaire
commune
et un terminal en terre modulaire qu'il
joue un rôle très important dans les
livraisons des frais du lest deux côtés
de la chine en europe centrale
cette société commune jouera un rôle
important
quand il s'agira de nous offrir des
opportunités en question
nous avons également
consacré notre attention
à nos contacts
aérien si par exemple on crée
de nouveaux vols il y aura plus de
touristes qui vont venir dans notre pays
il faudra ajouter des vols de
yekaterinburg et de kaliningrad
des vols directs
budapest nous avons eu la promesse pour
l'avenir pour pour d'avoir des
négociations dans l'avenir de la dessus
je voudrais vous remercier pour vos
négociations d'aujourd'hui nous espérons
que dans l'avenir ce sera serré la même
réussite qu'à présent merci monsieur le
président maintenant on va passer à des
questions il y aura deux questions pour
chaque partie donc je donne la parole
aux collègues hongrois
bonjour la première question de la part
de la chaîne hongroise
un bon jour - pas le tube ayo j'aimerais
poser la question qui concerne tous les
deux dit nous s'il vous plaît à kiel
niveau et à quel point il peut parler
d'aujourd'hui ont pu renforcer la
sécurité dans les stations de gaz en
europe à merci
monsieur le premier ministre a posé
plusieurs questions
concernant l'expansion de notre
coopération cela concerne le domaine de
l'énergie en plus de différents aspects
la livraison des hydrocarbures je sous
entends le volume de gaz a fourni le
domaine du nucléaire la logistique les
transports la production industrielle
est aussi l'agriculture
directement au cours des pourparlers
avec monsieur le premier ministre
j'ai contacté un mes collègues à au sein
du groupe en russie avec certains
dirigeants des grandes de sociétés
russes est est pratiquement à toutes les
questions posées par messieurs les
premiers mini nous avons eu la réponse
positive cela concerne l'augmentation
des volumes de gaz à fournir mais tout
d'abord il faut regarder
il équilibre vraiment et le ratio de
gaza en interne en russie une fois que
lee la saison des verts soit achevé mais
je pense pas que un milliard de mètres
cubes de gaz 1 plus souvent un grand
problème pour nous surtout la question
leur volume dans les domaines
de stockage 1 euro par ont diminué de 55
millions de cubes si je me trompe pas
mais probablement nos partenaires en
europe pourrait avoir des problèmes mais
un green non ils n'auront pas de
problème parce que nous allons conserver
dévolu supplémentaires mais évidemment
des sociétés en coopération vont prendre
bientôt la décision nécessaire cela
concerne aussi le demi tour
et le bypass à côté de budapest que
monsieur le premier ministre a apposé je
pense à résoudre cette question parce
que pendant le chemin vers ici j'ai reçu
l'information supplémentaire je pars de
la ligne de crédit qui prévoit 2
milliards de dollars américains en plus
à pour ce projet pour faire le bail
passe à côté de budapest pour la
fourniture de gaz la concerne aussi
notre coopération dans le nucléaire
la formation des spécialistes
et la résolution de certaines questions
les la production du combustible
nucléaire et beaucoup d'autres et je
pense
que je suis je partage complètement
l'opinion de monsieur le premier
ministre que notre travail conjoint qui
a duré pratiquement cinq heures a été
assez fructueux et riche et réussi
pratiquement sur tous les axes surtout
nous avons discuté ce différentes
facettes l'agriculture aussi au niveau
de la résolution des problèmes et
questions énergétiques 1
je voudrais dire aux journalistes russes
aujourd'hui dans l'europe occidentale le
coût du gaz et de l'électricité a
augmenté de 2 ou 3 fois
ça pose un grand problème aux
populations
la hongrie ran est une exception
pendant de longues années en hongrie
nous réduisons les coûts
pour des services communautaires
le gaz russe si nous avons le gaz russe
nous pouvons
fournir par ce gas les ménages hongrois
d'une manière assez pas cher si on n'a
pas de gaz russe ont peut pas le faire
du point de vue des populations
hongroise il est très important que nous
avons nous sommes proches d'avoir un
accord sur en milliards de mètres cubes
de plus de les raisons chaque année
depuis la russie de cette manière là
nous avons sécurisé et finalement les
livraisons en hongrie en ce qui concerne
la centrale nucléaire apax en 2030
grâce à cette centrale
une autre on aura la couverture de 90 %
de nos besoins un d'énergie sans cela on
peut pas voir notre politique
énergétique
cette négociation a porté sa
contribution
interfax vous avez déjà évoqué la
coopération contre le co lead
dans le cadre de cette conférence de
presse ce jour de savoir quand peut-on
s'attendre à ce que le vaccin de
spoutnik vais soit produit en hongrie y
aura-t-il des achats de spoutnik light
pour vacciner la population hongroise
ou bien
s'il y aura la licence pour produire
spoutnik light en anglais j'suis
permettez je vais commencer si j'ai bien
compris au niveau politique il n'y a pas
de problème à ce niveau pas c'est que
l'homme qui a été le premier pays
européen qui a fait les acquisitions de
spoutnik vue actuellement nous sommes en
train de négocier à l'achat de spoutnik
l'aïe qui pourrait servir dieu vaccin de
rappel pour assurer les arts vaccination
qui ont utilisé
d'autres vaccins de production
européennes et américaines et nous
sommes en train d'étudier la question
de la localisation de la production de
spoutnik la terre parce que ce travail
est en cours est ce un caractère
technique jeu j'espère que ce soit
résolue dans l'immédiat
l'application de ce pique nique light en
hongrie elle doit ce vaccin doit avoir
cette autorisation dont six ont déjà été
obtenus donc l'avenir la plus proche la
hongrie va acheter spoutnik light dans
notre pays tous les accents sont
accessibles comme nous avons une
expérience positive accumulée dans le
domaine de la gestion des vaccins en du
spoutnik vais ce sera correct si les
citoyens ont droit et l'accès également
à sportica et nous allons lancer une
usine de modules erp qui
commencera à fonctionner en fin de cette
année on va produire
ce pique nique light esprit ne crois pas
en plus la hongrie a approuvé mobiliser
le spoutnik et v et enregistré si je me
trompe pas parce que aujourd'hui les
messieurs le premier ministre a posé la
question à qui prévoit l'augmentation du
nombre des échanges aériens entre les
deux pays je pense que ce sera étudiée
avec réponse positive très bientôt
maintenant j'aimerais il a posé la
question de la part de la hongrie je
vous remercier
j'aimerais vous demander
au cours des pourparlers si vous avez
discuté des nouveaux aspects de la
coopération économique entre les deux
pays que nous n'avons pas entendu
jusqu'à présent
tout d'abord il faut savoir que
l'économie russe
à cause des sanctions
qu'elle avait subis et finalement
l'économie russe ait résisté parce que
si vous regardez les chiffres vous allez
voir que l'économie russe est beaucoup
plus robuste
par rapport ce que l'on est
l'on considère à l'occident et la russie
est un pays non seulement de
l'opportunité du passé mais aussi du
futur nous avons discuté de nouvelles
opportunités des possibilités sur le
plan économique et la politique des
sanctions imposées contre la russie a
fait beaucoup plus de préjudice à
l'engrais par rapport la russie
la russie a mis en place un système de
ce type i tition aux importations dans
les domaines où nous avions fourni une
eau propre marchandises actuellement
nous avons perdu le marché parce que on
a fait la russie se développer de telle
façon que certains pays y compris lhenry
perdent leur part du marché comme landry
et la politique de sanctions au final a
vraiment une influence
à l'opposé par rapport à ce qui est
déclaré comme le but des sanctions parce
que les sanctions par défaut qui sont
vouées à l'échec et c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas considère pas acceptables ni à
l'égard de leurs signes à l'égard
d'autres parce que landry a fait
beaucoup d'investissements sur la
frontière en gros une chrétienne
nous avons vu apparaître beaucoup de
milieux criminels qui est très
moderne qui est beaucoup plus apte
et surtout grâce à ce terminal qui
assure le transit de marchandises est
parce qu il s'agir des possibilités
énormes et nous avons discuté du fait
entre autres nous allons créer une
société mixte en gros aux russes sur le
plan logistique qui va assurer les
transports et je suis sûr que nous
allons réussir sur ce projet ce qui
permettrait d'augmenter le succès de
l'économie hongroise et nôtres permettra
de profiter d'une bonne position
géographique de la hongrie qui est très
bonne pour les itinéraires de transport
pour les lignes pour les conduites à
pour le chemin de fer pour cette raison
en commun avec la russie nous pourrions
bénéficier de cette bonne situation
géographique
j'ai déjà répondu par le passé à votre
première question et j'ai déjà mentionné
sur le plan logistique nous avons de
très bonnes possibilités et opportunités
et j'aimerais confirmer ce qui a été dit
par mon homologue
c'est tout à fait vrai la direction de
la cité chemins de fer russes rjd leur
concert en tant qu' un projet éventuel
en plus c'est une grâce à la proposition
du monsieur le ministre nous pourrions
créer des
coentreprises
pour assurer le développement de cette
infrastructure d'être un sport parce que
c'est notre intérêt ou ici à nous nous
sommes prêts à travailler et j'ai déjà
mentionné entre autres l'agriculture
parce qu il ya notre culture
traditionnelle qui prévoit la fourniture
sur notre marché des produits en droit
mais il ya aussi d'autres aspects non
traditionnels comme par exemple la mise
en circulation de l'agriculture des ter
rue sa donation de l'agriculture et la
production de thé les marchandises qui
sont extrêmement demandés sur le marché
mondial parce qu'il y en a beaucoup de
marchandises de ce type c'est l'un des
axes éventuelle de notre coopération
en jouant au futur
allez-y live bonjour ma question
concerne et de laideur le premier
ministre envoie en tant que leader d'un
pays qui fait partie de l'union
européenne et de l'otan à la fois
comment évaluez-vous les négociations
entre la russie et le temps le sait les
états unis et ma question pour le leader
russe vous avez dit justement que dans
les réponses que vous avez reçus depuis
les america et des américains et du loto
les préoccupations principales ont été
ignorés
comment allez-vous répondre à ces
réponses qui sous quelle forme qu'est ce
que vous allez répondre vous pourriez
vous nous faire revoler un petit peu le
contenu de ces papiers est votre réponse
et comment carte sd vous la situation
sécuritaire autour de l'ukraine kiev
commence déjà à faire de la déclaration
officielle disant que si les accords de
minsk sont respectées le pays vous sera
cassé
la gestion et complique la situation est
compliquée
les
différences
sont énormes
ce que la russie veut le monde entier
pour leur savoir et c'est vrai que les
réponses données à ces préoccupations
le besoin de sécurité deux côtés de la
rue si la réponse de l'état sont loin
encore
les uns des autres
même si cette distance est grande
on peut pas dire que ses distances et
insurmontable aujourd'hui j'ai pu me
rassurer que les différends dans les
positions peuvent être surmontées qu'on
peut parvenir à des accords qui
garantiront la paix et la sécurité de la
russie
et ce sera acceptable pour que les pays
de l'otan
une telle un tel accord est possible
j'espère que les négociations dans les
jours à venir vont mener un accord de ce
genre à
regarder
j'aimerais expliquer encore une fois la
logique de notre comportement et de nos
propositions comment il est connu on
nous a donné des promet de ne pas à
faire la jirs l'infrastructure de l'otan
vers l'est ni d'un seul coup
c'est universellement connu actuellement
nous voyons où se trouve le temps la
pologne la roumanie
les pays bas étaient
on nous a dit une chose mais on a fait
le contraire qu'on m'a dit chez nous
dans notre peuple ah
ah ça a été vraiment le mensonge
en plus les etats unis se sont retirés
du traité
anti missiles et n'est fait nous avons
demandé depuis longtemps de ne pas le
faire parce que sait-on des traités
fondamentaux qui sécurise la situation
mais les etats unis se sont retirés et
actuellement leur poste de
lance-missiles
de
l'on dit le système anti mais se trouva
en pologne roumanie et là bas en plus il
y à des pots de lacement mk 40e alors
qu'ils peuvent être munis de thomas wac
est ce qu'il s'agit non plutôt non des
antilles messieurs les systèmes de
frappes des missiles d'attac qui puisse
couvrir notre hauteur et tout voir pour
des milliers de kilomètres est-ce que
c'est pas un vrai menace pour nous en
plus et on nous dit le pas suivant c'est
l'ukraine parce qu'il faut qu'il soit
adopté à l'otan écoutez ça me plaît
écoutez attentivement ce que je vais
dire
bah c'est que dans les deux qui m'ont
basiques de doctrine ukrainien il est
dit que l est prévu que faire revenir à
la craie mais par la voie militaire ce
qui est écrit dans leur document
imaginons nous que la kul prennent
certains membres est un membre de l'otan
qui est muni des systèmes de frappe
moderne des armements comme la roumanie
la pologne qui ce qui va empêcher et du
coup d'un seul coup on a commencé
l'opération a créé mais je parle me
plaît même pas du donbass pas ce que
c'est vraiment la crème et les
territoires russe s avéra parce que là
dessus dans ce sens pour nous à la
question est close imaginons que à
l'ukraine s'est on est un membre de
l'otan dans ce cas là qu'est ce que nous
devons faire ne s que nous devons faire
la guerre contre
l'alliance le temps est ce que quelques
idées déjà penser à réfléchir à ce poids
à part mon nom personne ni à réfléchir
en plus en ce qui concerne le respect
des accords de misc du mbba on nous dit
on entend que l'ukraine veut les
respecter chaque fois on me dit qu'ils
signent un autre fou de ne pas respecter
les accords de misc mais un public qui a
un grand public on entend que si
l'ukraine respect des accords de miss qu
elle va se désintégrer
mais personne n'a apparemment réfléchi
au fait que tu me parles créer des
menaces similaires non seulement pour la
russie mais aussi pour les prenne
elle-même tout cela dans l'ensemble ce
sont des questions qui nécessitent
vraiment une haute idée très détaillée
la prise en compte et d l'intérêt
bilatéraux et récits pour chaque fois on
nous dit que chaque pays à la possible
de choisir le système d'un procès pour
garantir sa sécurité mais je suppose que
les états unis pensent plutôt non
seulement de la sécurité à ne créer mais
plutôt sur au deuxième plan mais leur
tâche primordiale c'est vraiment
d'assurer et adam de gêner le
développement de la russie d'empêcher le
développement de l'art ici parce que le
crâne c'est vraiment juste un outil pour
atteindre ce but on peut le faire de
façon différente parents ont le faisant
participer à quelques conflits armés en
plus en faisant leur allié en europe à
imposer des sanctions très sévères et
dur contrôle et a réussi dont on en
parle en europe actuellement et en
essayant de faire
adhérer l'ukraine à l'otan un nid
fournissant des systèmes d' attaques de
frappe des koopmans comme bender a pour
faire revenir le donbass et les creux
mais par une voie armée en ne faisant
participer à des conflits armés et si
nous regardons
toutes ces questions à multi facettes au
sérieux profondément il devient clair
que en essayant d'éviter le
développement est négatif des événements
ce que nous voulons faire il faut
prendre en considération des intérêts de
tous les pays sur qui y compris la
russie il faut trouver la solution pour
ce problème dans quel but est ce que ça
vous signer des accords à istanbul et
astana qui disait clairement d'une façon
écrite qu'un camping peut assurer sa
propre secrétaire au détriment préjudice
des autres c'est pour ça que nous disons
que l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan
sapin et fragilise notre sécurité
et à chaque fois on en parle de la
politique des portos vermelles 12 que
vienne ses racines ou est ce que parce
que l'article 10 du traité de 1949 si je
me trompe pas qui prévoit la mise en
place de l'otan l'article 10 dit que
l'alliance
de l'accord avec tous les états membres
de l'otan peut
assurer l'adhésion d'autres états
européens dans cette allée en à cette
organisation peu mais il n'est pas
obligé c'est pour ça que les nations
unies y compris l'automne peuvent dire à
l'ukraine nous voulons assurer votre
sécurité parce que c'est important pour
nous nous respectons votre respiration
mais nous pouvons pas vous accepter
parce qu'il ya déjà d'autres engagements
internationaux que nous avons assumé par
le passé est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui soit pas clair y compris pour le
crime et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
trouver une solution
pour assurer la sécurité et expliquer à
tous les états membres de l'otan et l
ukraine et la russie mu n'est possible
qu'à condition de faire une étude très
approfondie sérieuse du document que
nous avons ou semi j'espère que ce
dialogue soit poursuivi et hier avec le
président français nous sommes mis
d'accord que probablement il va venir a
personnellement à moscou et avec lui je
vais en discuter personnellement de
toutes ces questions et j'espère que
finalement nous allons trouver cette
solution mais on ne comprend pas très
bien que ce soit pas une solution
facile mais je suis pas capable de dire
exactement de quoi il s'agit aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup de votre attention chers
collègues merci beaucoup